hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a horror thriller film called
walden
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins with a young girl
trapped in between walls
not long after cement begins pouring
down on her from all angles
the little girl cannot go anywhere else
she is buried alive
the scene moves to 15 years later a
young engineer
sam has just graduated from college at
her graduation party
her father an owner of a demolition
company gives her a gift
a job supervising the demolition of a
building in the middle of nowhere
if she's successful she will become his
partner her first assignment happens to
be this gigantic unique architectural
structure
an apartment building located out in the
middle of nowhere
the structure is the product of joseph
malistraza who was an eccentric
architect obsessed with egyptian
architecture
samantha arrives at the malistraza
building and is greeted by mary the
caretaker
she lives with her son jimmy who is a
loner kid
sam tells mary she will be staying in
one of the apartments in the building
jimmy takes her bags to her apartment
and explains the rules of the building
she is to stay off the eighth floor
because it is malistraz's and the roof
because it is too dangerous
as she is walking to her room she sees a
room labeled as julie's
she then enters her room and immediately
takes a bath to clean herself up
later that day she meets mary and asks
her how many people still live in this
apartment
mary replies that only four people live
in it mary and jimmy are in the building
to look after it until its day of
destruction
all the other tenants have been evicted
but two have refused to leave
the next day sam prepares to analyze the
structure of the building
sam is in charge of providing a report
on how much tnt is needed to knock down
this building
she must determine the best rupture
points and type of explosives
a few hours later she goes to a mini
market to buy some food and drinks
out of curiosity she borrows a computer
to browse the history of the apartment
building
she discovers that in 1993 there were a
series of missing people
when they were finally found it was
horrific 16 people
men women and children were sealed in
small compartments in the building
which were then filled with liquid
concrete one of the victims was the
architect himself malistraza
a construction worker was initially
blamed for the murders but then found
innocent
leaving the crimes unsolved and the
murderer unknown
back at the building sam again marks the
best rupture points to knock down the
building
but she is surprised when a man runs
towards her carrying an axe
it turns out that this man is one of the
tenants who still lives in this building
and refuses to leave
and he is unhappy about the destruction
of the building at night
jimmy secretly takes sam to the eighth
floor the forbidden floor
jimmy tells sam about malistraza the
architect of the building
who died inside the wall he enters a
room and shows her the wall where
malistraz's body was found
when his body was found his face was
almost ripped off because of the cement
his face was no longer recognizable his
mother
mary was the one who finally managed to
identify him
jimmy also informs her that out of the
16 victims there was a small child named
julie
she was the child shown at the beginning
of the film she was also the child
living in the room sam saw before
furthermore jimmy tells her that his
father was also one of the victims
he then proceeds to show her the wall
where his father was found
the lights go out and sam cuts her leg
after panicking in the darkness
later jimmy washes her wound and begins
to caress her thigh
it becomes obvious that the young guy
fancies her and he tries to make a move
on her
but she tells him to stop in the evening
sam who is looking in the mirror sees
the glass behind her shaking violently
she lifts the mirror and sees blood
flowing out of the hole
suddenly sam is immediately pulled into
the wall and she wakes up realizing that
she is now trapped inside
a moment later cement begins pouring
down on her from all angles
she cannot go anywhere else as she
starts screaming
she wakes up from her sleep it turns out
to be a nightmare
as she can no longer sleep she wanders
around her apartment
suddenly something appears
however it's just her boyfriend peter
who wants to give her a surprise
sam takes peter to look around the
apartment they secretly go to the eighth
floor
while exploring the eighth floor sam and
her boyfriend discover a secret
passageway on the floor
sam goes down it and she discovers a
secret room
this room would allow someone to view
any of the apartments secretly
sam realizes that jimmy has been spying
on her while she's taking a bath
she talks to mary about it and jimmy who
feels embarrassed
walks away later that evening
peter thinks that sam should leave
tomorrow and she agrees with him
as peter and sam spend their time
together that night jimmy grows jealous
of them
the following day sam packs her clothes
to leave the apartment
she also prepares a report on how much
tnt is needed to knock down this
building
before parting jimmy apologizes to sam
for spying on her
he then gives a gift to sam he gives him
a copy of the journal of malistraza
the building's architect sam realizes
from reading the journal that there must
be a large open space in the center of
the building
jimmy goes to the roof to look for an
opening to the hidden space
however he does not return sam and her
boyfriend follow to look for jimmy
they discover a massive shaft in the
center of the building
they hear jimmy calling from down in the
shaft saying that he is hurt
sam has her boyfriend lower her into the
shaft on a rope
at first everything goes smoothly
without any problems at all
but suddenly peter is shot by someone
with sharp iron
as a result peter dies bleeding in front
of his girlfriend
who shocked seeing this sam falls to the
bottom
sam awakens at the bottom of the shaft
surprisingly
she is not alone there there is a
mysterious person
to her surprise that mysterious man is
malistraza
the architect who she thought has been
dead entombed in the wall
it turns out that he has been trapped
there this whole time malestrazza is
holding a radio
in the radio recording there is jimmy's
voice asking for help
in other words the voice that sam hurt
earlier is pre-recorded by jimmy himself
shortly jimmy sends her a letter from
above in the letter
it is written that jimmy is keeping her
down there until she learns to love him
jimmy then mails sam's demolition report
to her father and sinks her car into a
lake
this is all done to create the
perception that sam hasn't returned home
because she goes on vacation with her
boyfriend
back in the shaft malistraza tells her a
shocking revelation
he reveals that he was the mastermind
behind the murders of 16 people
who were found entombed in the wall
malistraza believes that the secret to
the longevity of ancient egyptian
monuments is that they conducted rituals
during construction that involved
burying living victims inside the walls
he wants his buildings to last forever
so he buried people alive inside its
walls
he further reveals that one of the
victims was mary's husband
so as an act of revenge mary decides to
keep malistraza locked up in the shaft
forever as a prisoner mary also fooled
everybody by identifying other victims
body as malistraza's
everyone believed that lyon thought that
malistraza had died
so that she can keep malistraza herself
as her prisoner
after this shocking revelation jimmy is
back at the hole and sends down a
cassette tape
malistraza plays the tape and jimmy says
that he wants to see sam and malestraza
dance
malistraza tells her that they need to
obey jimmy's order
if they do what jimmy wants jimmy is
nice but can be very cruel and
imaginative if they disobey jimmy's
orders
so sam agrees to dance but when jimmy
tells them to kiss
she refuses malastraza pulls her close
and forces her to kiss him
after a few seconds jimmy tells them to
stop and threatens malistraza not to
touch sam again
as a gift for their obedience jimmy
sends down a basket with food
water and a two-way radio he tells sam
to keep the radio with her so that they
can talk and be close
later that night mary comes to the roof
sam immediately screams to get help from
mary
mary is very surprised to see sam in the
hole with malistrassa
mary angrily tells jimmy that the place
was for the architect
not for anyone else she realizes that
sam must stay in the hole with
malistraza or else she'll report this
incident to the police
and they'll take mary away and jimmy
will be an orphan
in the afternoon sam's father and his
demolition team
who have received sam's report arrive at
this apartment
they begin to set up the explosives
elsewhere
sam is still stuck in the hole with
malistrasa sam continues to seduce jimmy
hoping that he will free her and save
her from the explosion
however her effort is unsuccessful
seeing this
malistraza tells her to save her energy
malistraza then digs a tomb that he has
designed with several pipes connected to
the cement tank
malistraza believes that when the
detonation team tries to knock this
building down
it will not be destroyed if an
additional person is buried alive
he decides to sacrifice himself to save
this building
he then asks sam to kill him she
eventually does kill him after some
taunting and he thanks her after he
falls into his tomb and it begins to
fill with cement
meanwhile outside the building mary is
keeping jimmy calm as they set up and
begin to install the explosives
as the countdown begins jimmy starts to
change his mind
he screams sam's name and runs toward
the building sam's father tells them to
stop the countdown
at the roof jimmy looks down and her
father asks what they have done
jimmy then throws himself over killing
himself and lands next to sam sam is
then lifted out of the hole and put in
an ambulance
mary is arrested as she is involved in
the kidnapping of malistraza
at the end of the film sam narrates that
malestrazza built 27 buildings and that
they are all still standing he
considered this apartment building as
his masterpiece
he didn't want it to be demolished he
even sacrificed himself to save the
building
so as a sign of respect this building
will not be demolished and will remain
his legacy
and that's how the movie ends subscribe
for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching